nearly 3,000 people attended the tribe
of Nova Festival in Rim Israel on
[Music]
Saturday it would become one of the
deadliest sites of hamas's surprise
attack on
Israel over 250 bodies have been
recovered from the festival grounds and
surrounding area here's how the attack
unfolds
the festival took place just 3 mil from
the Gaza Strip attendees arrived by car
and bus on
Friday just before sunrise on Saturday
the allnight Rave is still in full
[Music]
swing at around 6:30 a.m. concert goers
notice a barrage of
rockets soon after the music
halts
as the Rockets continue Festival
organizers tell attendees to
leave around 7 a.m. confusion turns to
panic as attackers reach the
festival
many attempt to escape via dirt roads
that lead to a main road but it creates
bottlenecks drivers encounter gunfire
from multiple
directions
yo
many like d'vorah Abraham abandon their
vehicles to take
cover one car makes it out and drives
South but just before 7:40 a.m. they
encounter a group of Hamas
Fighters 20 minutes later on the same
road more Fighters are seen closer to
the festival assaulting civilians at a
bomb
[Music]
shelter the southern Escape Route is now
blocked around 8:30 a.m. security
attempts to hold off Hamas Fighters
approaching the festival from the
north
that Escape Route is now blocked
too large groups make desperate attempts
to flee running across Open
[Music]
Fields others remain at the
grounds hiding in
dumpsters and seeking protection from
security person
[Music]
out
just before 9:30 a.m. Hamas Fighters can
be seen hunting down anyone remaining on
the
grounds someone appearing to play dead
moves a fighter notices and executes
them survivors the journal spoke to
describe an hours long ordeal of being
hunted by Hamas
militants d'vorah Abraham moves from
place to place to stay
[Applause]
alive after many hours she makes it to
safety
those who didn't Escape were killed or
taken
hostage many were brought back to Gaza
and paraded through the
streets in a video circulated by Hamas
Affiliates one captive can be seen
wearing what looks like the blue
Festival
wristband many attendees remain
unaccounted for Hamas has since pledged
to execute hostages as retaliation for
Israeli air
[Music]
strikes